tv.org [ __ ] oh this is on our good
evening everyone and welcome to
tonight's event with Dean Baker he's
going to talk to us tonight about his
newest book rigged for those of you who
may not know Dean the only thing he
likes more than grabbing catchphrases
from Donald Trump are his dog that was
my one joke I have nothing else uh so
without further ado I'll go ahead and
let Dean takes us take the stage
everybody Dean Baker yeah thank Donna
and I do like my dog that's pretty great
well I've had three great Dobermans the
other one is pit bull in a bichon so
that's that's the crew today
so anyhow so I'm here to talk about my
book rig which kind of is things I've
been talking about for at least a couple
decades in economics and sort of a
chance to put it together just to put as
simply as possible but the main theme of
the book is we've had this huge upward
redistribution of income over the last
four decades it's really not arguable at
this point I mean it's been documented
in a number of ways people probably
heard of Paquette e thomas piketty's
great book capital that really talks
more about wealth but in any case we've
had a number of you know good reports
solid data documenting this huge upward
redistribution of income and just one of
my favorites this is actually Paquette
Ian's Carter says and I believe it was
sucked when was the third author but it
showed that if you look at the United
States and if you look at the bottom
half of the income distribution they
basically got nothing since 1980 okay I
won't stand by the literal nothing and I
know I have many comments would jump off
on me and say well if you count this and
you count that I don't care it's
positive but the point is you've had
four decades in which we've had
substantial economic growth substantial
innovation and a large share of the
public has almost nothing to show for
so that I consider not really an
arguable point at this you know right
now the question is why is that and the
conventional view among economists and
certainly you know I would say among
policy people in Washington is well you
just Campins you know that was
globalization that was technology and
you know we might feel bad about it I
kind of make a joke about this that you
know we on the one hand have the
Liberals who can't feel bad about it and
the other ones the Conservatives go well
it's good we want more you know so but
in both cases they see it is you know
being something that happened and the
main point of my book is no it's not
something that happened it's something
we did and what I want to go through is
three major areas the first is
globalization talk about trade the
impact of globalization on workers in
the United States the second one is the
Federal Reserve Board and people might
think is real wonky and it is a little
bit wonky but the basic point isn't the
Federal Reserve Board is hugely
important in affecting both the number
of jobs in the economy and the wages
that workers get and the third is
patents and again that might sound
really weird why the hell do I care
about patents well patents are a huge
amount of money and the fact that a lot
of people including a lot of economists
type people don't seem to know that it's
really incredible and really speaks to I
think an enormous failing of the
economics profession
all right well starting with the story
with globalization the classic stories
it's told as well you know we just
happen to be the case that there's all
these people in the developing world who
are willing to work for very low wages
or very poor and you know they undercut
you know all our steel workers our auto
workers and that's just the way of the
world
you know we're just going to have to get
used to it that you know if you don't
have a college degree if you don't have
advanced education you can't compete in
the world economy and you know again we
could be good liberals and feel bad
about those workers who lost their jobs
in Ohio and Pennsylvania and other
places or it could be concerns and just
go to bad folks well what I want to say
about that is that story is
fundamentally wrong and it's wrong in
just about every respect you know the
place where I start the book I pick up
on the theme that we saw back in the
primaries in March I attributed this to
box and maybe wrongly indicted them but
you know I first saw this in box where
they said Oh Bernie Sanders is the enemy
of the world's poor
and the basic story you know here you
had Bernie Sanders saying you know look
I want to protect jobs from
manufacturing workers of the United
States and the argument was well that
has been the story of development in
places like China the rest of the
developing world that they got those
jobs and that led to them getting out of
extreme poverty and we should really be
very happy about that and Bernie Sanders
is their enemy well that story's
fundamentally wrong for a number of
reasons first off the idea that we have
to displace workers in Pennsylvania and
Ohio to accommodate the output of the
world's poor in China and the developing
world that's fundamentally wrong and
it's not hard to show that first off the
basic theory the economic theory that
you know I learned to grad school and I
don't think it's change that much is
you're supposed to have money going from
rich countries to poor countries it's
supposed that capital flow from rich
countries to poor countries the money
should be going from the United States
to China to Malaysia to other poorer
countries reason why that matters is
that would mean that we would be running
trade surpluses with those countries
they would be using that money they
would be bowing from us
to build up their infrastructure build
up their capital stock and at the same
time they would be able to support the
living standards of their population and
then actually happened in the 1990s we
actually saw that the rich countries as
a whole had large trade surpluses with
the developing world not the u.s. but if
you add in Japan and you're up there
large trade surpluses and the countries
of the region particularly countries
like Vietnam Malaysia they're running
very large trade deficits and guess what
they were growing very rapidly if they
continued that rate of growth they would
be much richer today than they are in
fact I have a little graph in my book
that shows that you would actually have
a situation where South Korea and
Malaysia would both be richer than the
United States on average if they
continued that rate of growth now they
didn't because you're these states and
financial crisis in 1997 but often say
this is the root of all evil
after the East Asian financial crisis in
1997 developing countries began to run
large surpluses and the story here was
they felt they had to accumulate large
amounts of reserves the reason was the
bailout from the financial crisis and
here my villains are people like Alan
Greenspan and
summers and Robert Rubin they imposed
very harsh terms on those countries they
didn't want have to deal with the IMF
after that that wasn't just a lesson
they learned in East Asia that was a
lesson they learned in Latin America
South Asia basically anyone in a
position that accumulate reserves in the
developing world did so after 1997 what
that meant was these countries instead
of running trade deficits borrowing
money from rich countries were net
lenders that's a very very perverse
story so the people who argue for the
current system I'm sorry
they were the enemies of the world poor
not for any Sanders okay again that's
true in both theory and we could look at
that period 1990 97 do I ignore it
you're welcome to ignore it but that's
not reality okay second point about this
a lot of people in the developing world
you know happy to work for a buck an
hour it's better what they were doing
competing with our factory workers in
Michigan Ohio and all that that's all
true guess what there's a lot of really
smart people in the developing world who
would be happy to train as doctors
lawyers dentists trained to our
standards and they would be happy to
work in the United States for lower pay
than our doctors our lawyers are they're
professionals well that's very difficult
to do because we have a lot of
protectionism for doctors dentists and
other professions doctors one I know
best you get arrested if you practice
medicine the United States without
having completed us residency program
okay we want to incur we want to assure
high standards for our doctors but I
don't think anyone could tell me with a
straight face that you don't have
competent doctors in places like Germany
Canada and France none of whom have
passed the US residency program that's
in call protectionism okay and as the
result of that our doctors on average
get paid more than 250,000 a year if you
compare that to Canada Germany the other
countries it's about twice as much okay
when you pay a really huge price for
that the difference between what we pay
our doctors what we pay doctors in
Germany France other wealthy countries
that comes about a hundred billion a
year that's real money okay that comes
to about seven hundred dollars a person
I'm sorry about three hundred dollars a
person for every person in the country
okay that's real money
and that's protectionism we never hear
that talked about we don't hear about
the AMA being the enemies of the world's
poor because they support protection
not even on the agenda okay let me
mention one last point in terms of trade
and globalization a big part of our
trade deals and certainly with the
trans-pacific partnership a big part of
our trade deals has been 180 degrees at
odds with free trade a big part of our
trade deals has been about increasing
patent and copyright and related
protections and I understand those give
incentives but those are protections
those are protectionism and they create
huge distortions in the market and I
focus on prescription drugs because it's
probably most egregious there but you
have situations where your drugs that
would be very cheap almost invariably
drugs would be cheap in a free market
they're cheap to manufacture they're
expensive because of patent protection
and I'll just take one that's been in
the news so so body the hepatitis C drug
a three month course of treatment lists
for eighty four thousand dollars in the
United States you can get a high quality
generic in India for $200 I'm saying
high quality the same sort of thing you
would get here so it's not that you're
getting some cheap stuff that's going to
kill you it's the same drug okay that's
equivalent to a forty thousand percent
error okay invariably when I say that to
people including comments they're
looking to go will the best patent
that's not tariffs so you call anything
you like it has the same impact on the
market and to give you an idea the
impact in the United States well I'll
put that off for now because we can come
back to patents in a minute but the
point here is that we've made poor
people in the developing world pay lots
of money for things that would otherwise
be very cheap in other words if we just
let them buy drugs in a free market but
we just let them buy software in a free
market they would save large amounts of
money the Friends of poor people in the
developing world should be a hundred
percent opposed to things like
trans-pacific partnership or for that
matter the trips part of the WTO that
requires them to pay patent-protected
prices for a lot of items they would
otherwise be able to get at their free
market prices okay secondary the Fed and
monetary policy you know again I raised
this with people you know educated
people I'm not grabbing someone off the
street and they may be made that person
may be educated too if it's Washington
but in any case educated people I talk
about the Federal Reserve Board the
guard yeah that's really interesting you
know if I you're selling stock and bonds
now it really matters a huge deal how
many people here notice that the Fed
raised interest rates in person
okay good we got long form through here
but okay well I started struck by this
because okay a Fed raised interest rates
in December why did they do it they did
that to slow the economy okay they I'm
not giving away any secrets I mean they
say that it's not like it you know I'm
reading their minds i'm tributing bad
thoughts to them they that was the
reason okay they're worried that the job
market is getting too tight okay and you
go okay so you raise point interest
rates by a quarter point and like I say
at the end of the world but clearly the
direction is unambiguous it's just slow
the economy so let's just say it slows
the economy by tens of a percentage
point employee idea I mean that's a
ballpark number but you know I won't
swear by it so it slows the economy by a
tenth of a percentage well at the end of
the year you're talking about somewhere
around 150 thousand fewer jobs in the
economy all right now let's think about
Trump's carrier carrier show in Indiana
okay how many jobs are at stake there
700 okay so we have 2000 times as many
jobs at stake with this small interest
rate hike at the Fed no one paid
attention to it or very few people did
whereas Trump 700 jobs in Indiana good
thing for those people I'm glad they
said their work their jobs but you know
that got a huge amount of attention well
the point here with the Fed is that they
have enormous control over the number of
jobs in the economy and if we look at
the period since 1980 they've been much
more concerned about constraining
inflation at the cost of job growth and
one of the measures that you know I've
looked at I did book on full employment
with my friend Jared Bernstein a few
years ago one of the measures we looked
at was the gap between the measure of
sort of full employment level of
unemployment the Congressional Budget
Office comes out with this it's called
the non accelerating inflation rate of
unemployment they come out with that so
we looked at the difference between
between the actual rate of unemployment
and their measure of the neighbors so
we're not saying that they're God we're
just saying you know this is a non bias
measure that in other words they didn't
call us up and asked for it you know so
so they came out with their measure and
if you look at that in the period from
1947 to 1980 on average the unemployment
rate was about a half percentage point
below their measure of neighborhood
if you look at the period 1980 so I
think we looked through 2012 it was
about a full percentage point above and
even if you took out the years after
2007 you after the crash it was still
about two thirds of a percentage point
higher so what that means is we had much
more restrictive monetary policy higher
rates of unemployment by policy
okay another Fed you know if we talk to
the people the Fed they'd all have their
argument they're concerned about
inflation okay but the point is they
place much more effort on containing
inflation in the period since 1980 than
the period prior to 1980 now an
additional point that we make in that
book and I emphasize in this book is
that's not just you downsize the economy
so in other words if we envision a story
where the Fed you know restrains demand
in the economy so we have an
unemployment rate of 5 percent rather
than 4 percent it's not just that the
economy is a little bit smaller it has
huge distributional effects can we
analyze this that we found you know part
of this is a very strong racial
component to it so if we get the
unemployment rate down by a percentage
point we're going to get the
unemployment rate for african-americans
down by two percentage points it's a
very surprisingly strong relationship
and it's not like a law or anything but
you know it's a very very strong
relationship flipside of that if we have
the unemployment rate one percentage
point higher than necessary well for
African American it's two percentage
points higher than necessary for African
American teams it's about six to one
okay so that's who were putting out of
work hey also Hispanics it's about one
and a half to one for Hispanics relative
to whites but the other part of the
story is a wage story so if we talk
about you know less educated workers
workers without college degrees with
disproportionately those are the people
who are losing jobs you know so if
things get bad it tends not to be the
manager gets laid off it's going to be
that you know the waitstaff here it's
the retail clerk the person are
manufacturing you know an assembly line
those are the people who lose their jobs
and again part of the story that we had
in that book and I emphasize in this
book is if you look at patterns of wage
growth over the last 40 years the only
time where you saw a consistent strong
wage growth for those at the middle and
bottom of the income ladder were the
late 90s the years in which we saw very
low unemployment okay so we got down
employment right down to 4% is you
around average in 2000 that was when you
saw a good wage growth in fact wage
growth was somewhat more rapid for those
at the bottom the 10th and 20th
percentile of the wage distribution than
those at the middle and the top
so things were going the right way well
the larger point here is when you have a
fed of our Reserve Board that's
committed to maintaining higher rates of
unemployment with the idea of fighting
inflation that's downward pressure on
wages of less educated workers okay that
wasn't the market that wasn't God that
was the Federal Reserve Board okay they
have an argument for their policy but
the point is that's very much a policy
choice so to act like that was just
something that happened no that's simply
not true you know again it was something
we did and again I make this point they
do this and you know if you ever talked
you know not other evil people but it's
all sounds very sanitary you know that
we don't want the economy to overheat
like we're cooking abroad well I don't
want they kind of overheat you know but
the point is they're throwing people out
of work and very very few people realize
that I'll just add one other point a now
skip skip on to talking about patents
but we often hear this argument about
automation eliminating jobs and you know
how we're going to see you know that
there's not going to be any jobs for
less educated people because of
automation well that may or may not be
true in the sense that I don't know the
few journal think any of us do and our
predictions about these things generally
proven very bad in the past but one
thing I can say is for the president
that clearly is not the case the two
things to point to one is automations
productivity growth it's not like
something that's new and you know exotic
we've had automation forever so we've
had productivity growth there was
actually much more rapid in the 50s and
60s periods of low unemployment and I
should also say very good wage growth
okay up and down the income ladder okay
so the idea that somehow because we're
seeing productivity growth workers at
the bottom are going to be screwed no
there's nothing that does that the other
point is you go wait a second we're
worried about automation this really
speaks to the quality of economic
debates in this country or economic
policy debates we're worried about
automation destroying the jobs at the
same time the Fed thinks they have to
raise interest rates to destroy jobs
I'm sorry that doesn't make sense either
one of those could be true but they
can't both make sense obviously the Fed
doesn't think automation is going along
so rapidly that's going to destroy all
the jobs that's why they raised interest
rates okay they feel they have to they
want to have fewer people working so
it's not that wage pressure not have
inflation okay the third area is patent
policy and again I raised this all the
time with economists and they invariably
look at me like what are you talking
about
well I'll focus on prescription drugs
Susan to say that is the area where you
know this is their life is their health
but it's also a huge amount of money we
spent about four hundred thirty billion
a year on prescription drugs
it's about two point three percent of
GDP give you a metric I used in the book
as a metric of comparison what we spent
spend on food stamps you know I take
that well I know a lot of conservatives
like to beat up on food stamps and
they're talking about Obama's food stamp
nation this and that but it's a larger
sort of anti-poverty program we spend a
bit over 70 billion a year on that okay
so what we said on prescription drugs is
about six times what we spend on food
stamps I'm just giving it as metric a
lot of money at stake there okay well
how much will we spend
if we snap their fingers and we got rid
of patents and related protections
well almost invariably the drugs that
we're getting are cheap to produce it's
very rare that you have a drug that
actually costs a lot of money to
manufacture so I gave you the example
Savanti it was a ratio of four hundred
to one
okay that's extreme but ratio is 250 to
101 those aren't uncommon and even a
ratio ten to one let's your sailor tend
to work now meaning we'd spend forty
three billion a year for the drugs that
we're currently spending four hundred
thirty billion euro
okay well that's an incredible waste and
again you know the way I talk about this
it's exactly the same way that
economists talk about trade protection
so if I said oh I want to put a twenty
percent tariff on imported steel well
every economist said contrary to tell
you why that's bad that's creating a gap
between the free market price and the
protected price and you're giving steel
companies incentive to pay off
you know legislators and they're going
to high
lawyers to extended this all of which is
true okay they might exaggerate all of
which is true okay except when you have
patents that raise the price not by 20%
but by a thousand percent or ten
thousand percent well it's much more
true okay and drug companies have an
enormous incentive to a you know go to
Congress say okay we want longer and
stronger patent protections and they're
pretty damn good at that okay so they do
that all the time they misrepresent
their research they push drugs for
purposes where you know they might not
be appropriate if you turn on the TV I
don't watch that much TV but I almost
invariably see drug ads I guess I watch
the news that's an older audience so I'm
in that group but but invariably you're
seeing drug ads well what are they
telling me you know I mean it might not
be that fond of any eschar ads or
anything but at least I have some idea
what I'm getting with a car so I see
their drug ad Dorothy Hamill does the
the Olympic figure skater was
advertising and she still does it she
was advertising arthritis drug okay what
information gotta give me I mean it's
practically I even know she takes the
drug yourself I mean she skates around
goes oh you know I feel great now but
you know who knows that she even takes
it who cares you know I mean that's
giving these zero information but
obviously the drug company is done
marketing research and what they're
betting is that that's going to get me
or get someone suffering from arthritis
to go to their doctor and say hey why
don't you give me this drug I saw
Dorothy Hamill you know whatever this
it's not a way to get good medicine okay
but we see that you know for obvious
reasons they sometimes actually conceal
evidence that their drugs are harmful
biotics drug put out by Merck it's an
arthritis drug and guess what turns out
that it could be very bad for people
with our conditions and guess what else
a lot of people have arthritis also have
heart conditions people people died
because of that
okay they have a really big incentive if
they were selling it at the same price
of bottle aspirin
they wouldn't have reason to conceal the
evidence you give them a really big
incentive also just the nature of
research you know one of the promise
that you know I've had discussions with
people from you know the pharmaceutical
industry to go well you know as new
competitors coming out for sivadas I
don't talk about the 84,000 but you say
that's a list price no one pays at any
how I feel good we have this whole
industry of intermediaries good that's
good
you have the list price of 84,000 that's
not useful item but they go but you know
there's drugs in the pipeline that
they're going to be competing they might
bring down the price of 40,000 or
whatever go well actually that's not a
good story I mean it's a good story
where you have a monopoly on the drug
but in a free market would it make sense
you have what seems to be I'm not
speaking as a doctor just the layperson
followed the press seems to be a very
effective drug for hepatitis C does it
make sense to go out and spend a whole
lot of money developing a second and
third and fourth treatment for this same
condition which you now hasn't have an
effective treatment for I'm not saying
is zero reason you know because I'm sure
some people those other drugs will be
better for but I suspect if we were
sitting down and saying okay we're could
our research knowledge be best spent it
won't be developing the second third and
fourth cure for hepatitis C would be on
developing a cure for a drug where we
don't have a treatment okay so this I
would add is a really bad system of
financing research my preferred
alternative I'll just mention and go on
my preferred research is just direct
funding and again I get a lot of people
look at me like oh you want the
government ago have you heard the
National Institutes of Health
okay National Institutes of Health gets
32 billion a year roughly haven't looked
at their budget for this year roughly 32
billion a year funding from the federal
government and everyone agrees they do
great work the biggest lobbyist for our
pharma well for obvious reasons third
they do basically get the output and
able to get patents and make lots of
money on it but everyone agrees that you
know that you very effective work so if
you doubled or tripled the budget and
you could have private industry do it
that's fine
but the point would be that the research
should all be in the public domain both
in the sense that the results would be
public so that if someone's working on a
drug they post the stuff to the website
so others could benefit from that
knowledge but also the finished product
when you actually have a drug you have a
patent on something that's in the public
domain
it could be produced as engineering okay
and my argument would be we almost
certainly be way better off doing a
system like that then the current patent
system
okay well getting back to the underlying
issue here I just looked at this
literally last night if you just look at
drug patents alone you're talking about
somewhere in the order of 350 billion
extra spending and I checked this
against the wage income of the bottom
half of the income distribution social
security social security ministration is
that on this that's about 1.2 trillion
okay so if we snap their fingers and
said okay we got rid of drug pen so
we're going to give all the money to the
bottom half of the income distribution
that would be the same as increasing
their wages on the order of a third okay
that would make a real difference in
those people's lives okay now it's never
as simple as that I understand that I'm
just trying to point out the orders of
magnitude involved here and when I talk
about patents again drugs are front and
center but we see it same issue arises
in other areas an MRI why is expensive
you know I charge you I don't know
twelve hundred thirteen fourteen hundred
for an MRI screening what does it
actually cost you know well you need the
electricity you need a you know someone
who knows what they're doing to read the
x-ray and to give you MRI I don't know
100 200 bucks
that's because of patents okay and then
of course with other products you know
my iPhone okay that's much more
expensive because of patent protection
and for a long time I think they stopped
now but Samsung and Apple every time one
man came out with a new phone the other
immediately rushed into court with you
know a whole range of patent suits and
eventually they resolved this I think
they've resolved us where they agreed to
stop doing it it's not a good use of
resources okay so you know again I could
go on and more length about this but the
point is that our patent systems got to
be incredibly wasteful and there's a
huge amount of money at stake and again
this is not something that just happened
we've made patents longer and stronger
over the last 40 years
and it's overwhelmingly benefited people
at the top they're no homeless people
getting patent rights okay it's
benefiting people like you know Bill
Gates and I'll throw copyrights in there
as well Bill Gates and other very
wealthy people okay well I go on I beat
up on Wall Street in this I don't want
you to think that I left out Wall Street
I beat up on our system of executive
compensation and you know I'd argue that
basically CEOs run the companies in
their own interest and they're basically
rip off their shareholders that's why
you get someone like John stump the CEO
of Wells Fargo's in the news because
they broke the law you snake
counts well it walked away with over 100
million dollars I mean we could perhaps
be sympathetically has someone like
Steve Jobs who actually was innovative
produced products that people like it
you know she made lots of money perhaps
but most of these people are CEOs walk
away as tens of millions a year you're
very hard pressed to say what their
great contribution was to their own
business I'm not even talking about you
I think they were good people I'm just
saying
did they really do a lot for their
business the John Stumpf do a lot for
Wells Fargo getting them called before
Congress and facing all sorts of charges
that are you probably not but he walked
away with over a hundred million okay so
to sum up I just say you know we could
look back over the last four decades
there's no doubt there's been this
massive upward redistribution of income
it's well documented no one considers to
dispute that except at this point what I
would say is it was not something that
just happened it was something we did
and the main point here is we can on do
it and I'll just one way add one last
point which I really think front and
center I'm fine with tax and transfer
policy I spent a huge amount of my life
yelling about Social Security why it
shouldn't be cut so I think those that
you know and fine with that I think
those are good things but I think the
more important thing is to try to avoid
having this upward redistribution in the
market to begin with so in other words
first and foremost we need different
rules for the market so it doesn't lead
to the same sort of inequality that we
see today and that's you know that's
where I think the biggest dividends are
so I'll stop with that
and take questions yes sir
hiding Francisco here boys grade the
huge beak I wanted to touch on the point
of PvP and some of the other
intellectual property protections and
those policies you've previously
mentioned that a lot of these free trade
deals are protectionist really because
they have a they have all these now
beyond the glitz and glamour of the
building of global markets tearing down
barriers there are entire chapters about
protecting incumbent interests and
protecting intellectual property could
you talk a little bit more about why
wiser that disconnect why do you have
people like Jason Furman or Barack Obama
who filled salving bills overall but
then somehow underestimate or just so
overlook they overlook those chapters
that are more protectionist that in fact
set set up more barriers is like is it a
political calculus that's happening
there would it what is driving that
decision well I can't speak for any
particular individual I know Jason I
like them alone I really appreciate a
lot of the work he's done at the Council
of Economic Forum Fuhrman I guess he
probably still is the head of the
Council of Economic Advisors for the
next three days but but in any case you
know if he's done a lot of good work and
it's time there so I don't you know
again I don't know exactly his motives
but it's hardly a secret who was behind
negotiating you know the TPP in
particular I mean they had I think was
25 working groups and the Washington
Post analysis the members of the working
group these are overwhelmingly
represented in the industry so you had a
working group on intellectual property
you had people from you know Pfizer and
Merck and you know Microsoft and me I
don't know specifically those companies
but you have people from the big drug
companies the software industry so what
do we think they're going to do you know
they're designing a trade deal are
against the again design something with
you know how could we best disperse
technology innovation to the developing
world or are they going to design the
trade deal that deepens our pocketbooks
makes us richer so I think that was what
went on why does why do we Connor mr.
then that I think an awful lot of
economists never look at these things
you know so you know they here it's a
free trade deal you refer to as a free
trade deal I've been beating up on
reports go can't you just call the trade
to you you know you have to call the
free trade deal you know just call the
trade deal use a neutral term you know
so they're there in the view that the
mindset this is about expanding world
markets that's a good thing I have to
support it and if you could point out to
them that you know this is increasing
patent protection increasing copyright
protection asking it those are
protectionist those are their initial
reaction saying this having spoken a
number every time it's like well that's
a small sidebar and you know again if
you look at the TPP it's 180 degrees the
other way because there's not that much
to eliminate in terms of traditional
tariffs and quotas with these you know
we have trade deals already with six to
the eleven other countries and even the
other countries everyone's in the WTO so
there's limits to how high those tariffs
could be in any case so the actual
effect the impact of reducing these
barriers is fairly low on the other hand
the impact of increasing the barriers
and patent and copyright related
protections that could be quite large
but again the inclination of most
economists is that you know a ignore the
debt aspect and B if you could sort of
put their nose and go hey come on no
this is right here and give you the
chapter you can read it you know it's
like well that's not a big deal and you
know so I think I think there's real
strong prejudices to overcome but the
underlying issue you know why do we
negotiate things like that well people
with money and power want those deals
and that's why it takes the form it does
yes there would behind you sir I think
you so much for being here you were
talking about protectionism in certain
types of employment medicine law and I
was wondering what your thoughts were on
interest rates policy student loan debt
policies and how that helps justify
these sort of increased wages for these
types of professions when you look at
medicine doctors are coming out with
over $200,000 in debt and they say that
that's what justifies these you know
really increased wages in comparison to
other nations yeah that's a good
question you know I say a couple things
on a student enemy first off there's a
lot of garbage that in the sense of
these for-profit schools and it's a
different question what you're asking
but I you know that's something I'd love
to see us crack down on in the sense the
Obama ministration has done some of this
but we can go much further and not
letting people get heavily indebted with
government debt and you know I always
say this isn't a question of you know
regulating the market because you know
these you know these various for-profit
places want to charge people twenty
thousand are prepared to cough it up out
of their pocket go ahead and I wouldn't
like that but no one's going to do it
anyhow it's a question about subsidizing
and that's really pernicious because
they taxpayer money and at the end of
the day you're also this person stuck
with a worthless degree and you know
thirty forty fifty thousand in debt they
can never pay off
that's bad story all around but we talk
about doctors you know again we do a
very poorly designed education system
higher education system and it is a bad
story I won't say it goes that far and
justifying you know the the sorts of
pain that these people get because we
could just do the arithmetic on you go
okay so you're getting two hundred fifty
thousand a year on average I realize
it's less for general practitioners you
know family practice is around 200 or so
it's still not that low but you know
specialist three four hundred thousand
common but in any case so - we'll just
take the average 250,000 a year say you
have two hundred thousand in debt so you
pay that off over ten years that's
twenty thousand a year you know compare
that's 100 hundred twenty thousand and
you know say Germany or France you're
still way better off so I mean what I'd
like to say is reform of the education
system so you know someone doesn't have
to take on that debt because we know
that's going to tend to disc
urge more low-income moderate income
people because you know even if they
could see okay at the end of it you get
you know two hundred fifty thousand
years of doctor it's very scary for
someone coming from the background where
no one has any money suddenly have that
sort of debt so I think that's a really
big problem but that doesn't justify the
sorts of salaries we see
I asked you not thank you for coming and
discussing your button see we have a
question for you what do you think of
Philip Morales B's idea is that he is
paused in books like science Mart and
never let a good crisis go to waste he
talks about the neoliberal thought
collective even in science where he
talks about the whole process of
privatization for profit this production
of science and scientific research
actually into a deteriorating quality of
research and eventually having the
potential to stifle innovation and
change thank you yeah you know I know
Phil I've read some of stuff from years
ago I'm not sure if I've read his latest
work but I think the general point is
well-taken you know when you have you
know the privatization of research
privatization of knowledge it takes it
on a bad path I mean for obvious reasons
the point is you're trying to maximize
profit and you know it's not necessarily
attributing anything malicious to people
if you have a industry that you know
corporation they're there to maximize
profit so what they're trying to do with
their research is figure out how to get
as much money as possible and you know
again what I'm arguing for prescription
drugs you know I have a different
argument about pence more generally
because I don't think there's pernicious
outside of the the pharmaceutical
industry or medical care in general I
should say but I think the idea of
trying to promote more public research
what I propose for other industries is
that you know instead of you have a
patent length of 20 years I mean still
have that we're bound to that by treaty
it's hard to get out of you could have
someone voluntarily give up the patent
after say five years have a going public
domain - five is somewhat arbitrary
before it should be six I know but some
shorter period with the condition that
with the provision that you'll have
access to all this other research in the
public domain you may have heard of the
idea of copyleft that you you copyleft
business ideas where you say okay
something is is really available
you know it's developed by the free
software movement reference to software
but could be applied more generically to
you know patents of any type or
copyrights of any type but the idea was
okay we're developing the software
anyone who wants can use it as long as
that also is freely available if you
decide you want to have a patent on and
privatize away you got to talk to us
okay so that would be my vision for
patents outside of the pharmaceutical
industry basically the pharmaceutical
industry I'd like to see government
responsible and you want to rest people
if they want to do stuff on their own
their only concern would be their you
might be competing against the generic
that's selling at generic prices you
know so you spent oh so I never searched
you won't get your money back that's
your problem if you want to do is go
ahead and do it but you know for other
areas you know what I would propose is
you'd have a shortened patent period and
the reward for having the shortened
patent period is that you have access to
all this material in the public domain
that you could you know then freely use
so you know I take very seriously the
idea that you get bad research and you
slow research I mean there was a good
study Heidi Williams the professor at
MIT did this study a few years ago
looking at the the encoding of the human
genome and she found that four genes
that were done in the public domain
there's private company competing genes
that were done in public domain those
turned out the patents on those who's in
the public domain were much more turned
out to be much more profit or much more
useful I forget her exact criteria but
much more useful than the ones that were
done privately you know and again
understandably these roles than anyone
could work from them and you know it
just stands to reason we all know as any
conference we all think in our research
that if we're going to better research
that it's open you know as opposed to
you know I'm going to do this in a
cramped corner and no one gets it you
know publish my results that no one gets
to see how I got there well no one
thinks I would be a good way for
economics to advance and I think that's
true of science for general
yeah let me Mac in your oh I'm sorry
okay back in your student days on your
way to your PhD you certainly must have
been beat over the head over and over
again with tantowel there ain't no such
thing as a free lunch
and listening to you describing things
you know for instance the drugs and
talking about making the pills only
costs a few pennies but then you're
forgetting the you know the famous West
Wing scene where I think it's Josh Lyman
and the e responds yeah the cost of the
second bill may be competitive but the
cost the first bill is at the UN or
couple million dollars to get it
licensed and approved and paying for all
the other ones that failed you talk
about patent protection but that patents
are like licenses like regulations all
these kind of things that's what the
most recent what our current president
he life is coming in you know that
public discussion of draining the swamp
and so the the point to you is it's
certainly true that we can do things on
the pants that you're talking about but
the question is you can certainly
unleash we now have regulations we have
to have licenses not just to be a doctor
but to be a cosmetologist I mean you
name it does until versed have broke it
you had to have a license to drive a car
to pick up people to take them somewhere
I mean all this kind of stuff unless the
ideas you're talking about are all these
kind of top-down insights but you're
unwilling it seems like you're only
going to allow stuff they grow up from
the bottom up and
my last common event is on the Federal
Reserve you know why the Federal Reserve
raised the interest rate at the end of
Obama's term not at the beginning of the
term they raised it at the end because
he doesn't care about tongue meanness
now it's quite happy to crash it but
during his years he wanted the interest
rate as low as possible because it's
good for government you can borrow money
and people won't notice it well taking
the second point first I thought you
know the Fed indicated long before the
December increase when everyone thought
including them I'm sure that Hillary
Clinton was going to be President but
they were going to raise rates in
December I think the reason they he
didn't want them to raise rates for the
game is termeh the economy is going
through a toilet and you know they're
more willing to raise rates when the
economy you know certainly the job
market is much tighter today you have
more reason to be concerned about
inflation in 2017 than you did in 2009 I
think that's kind of straightforward
explanation again I still think they're
wrong to raise rates I think there's not
that much reason to be concerned but I
think that's kind of straightforward and
hard to get away from in terms of
patents no I do there's no free lunch in
my book I was talking about having the
government pay for the research so what
I'm saying is that we're paying four to
thirty billion for the drugs we snap our
fingers are available in a free market
40 billion 60 billion you pick your
number I think that's those are
reasonable numbers oh we'll take 60
billion okay so we have three hundred
seventy billion dollars to play with and
what I said is you need additional
funding for the research the
pharmaceutical industry says it spends I
think it's a forty seven billion a year
in research so we have to do what that
does
okay there's reasons to think that
public funding would be more efficient
for two reasons one you don't have the
incentive for copycat people aren't
going to produce the second third fourth
so body which you know probably aren't
that useful and secondly it's in the
public domain everything is public so
people could see benefit from other
people's innovations learn from their
mistakes but whatever stay across the 60
billion 70 billion say we have to spend
twice as much across this 90 billion
we're still ahead by somewhere in the
order of 250 billion dollars so I'm not
assuming any free lunch I'm talking
about different mechanism of financing
the research and one I'd argue is huge
more efficient but at the very least
what I want is to get this on the agenda
you know certainly it's a sort of thing
economist should be talking about there
are a few I mean there there's a great
book against monopoly by this guy David
Levine and Michelle Balder and I think
they're both they were both in
University of Washington and st. Louis I
don't know if that's still true or no
watching University in st. Louis so
there are you know and Joe Stiglitz
actually already known this among others
so there are some other economists but
in general it's not a major area of
research and it would certainly argue it
should be because there's an incredible
amount of money at stake and when you're
talking about drugs me this is people's
health as well you know we do seem to
feel that most of us do seem to feel
that's important there's a question up
here he is
you talk about trade agreements that
typically is new and nobody knows what
shape or form in my tape what about the
existing trade agreements in which we do
have decades of data I'm talking about
NAFTA for example you already have 25
years of experience I'm curious if in
your economic research have you done
have you reach any conclusions about the
net benefits of the opportunity cost of
eliminating some but something like
NAFTA for the three North American
economies and linked to that if you want
to address it I'm curious about the
wisdom of going for a free trade bloc
like the EU or piecemeal country by
country specifically to get address for
example okay so breaks it in the wisdom
of England for example doing a free
trade deal with America as opposed to
staying within the EU I know it is a two
separate projects well a few things I
mean with NAFTA any one things I was
striking the predicted result of NAFTA
you know I think economist were honest
about was that put downward pressure on
the wages of workers about college
degrees and I think it had that fact
wasn't huge I mean that what we saw in
the period after 2000 when China was
admitted to WTO dwarfed the impact of
NAFTA but you know there is some
research showing that in areas where
there was the most competition of
industries of Mexico that there was
significant downward pressure on wages
in those areas and you know so I think
that was a negative the story for Mexico
was not a good story I mean basically it
disrupted their semi subsistence
agriculture and you know one of the
amazing myths that you know I beat up on
the Washington Post because they just
literally made up a number on this like
you know I keep trying to pressure them
so you somehow get them to correct it
and in 2007 they were trashing the
Democratic candidates because also they
wanted to read negotiate an anthem they
said Nance it's been great for Mexico
their GDP is quadrupled between 1987 and
2007 well the actual number was 83
percent which is not quadrupling where I
come from you know but you know anyhow
but that missed that somehow NAFTA has
been great for Mexico
that is widespread Mexico's economy is
actually grown more slowly in the years
since NAFTA than the US economy and you
expect you know poor countries to
converge with rich countries hasn't
happened okay so you're pretty
hard-pressed to me maybe you know their
economy went down even worse absent
absent after what you can't rule out but
you're pretty hard-pressed to tell a
story that some other their country is
thrived since NAFTA the US point of view
I don't think it's been a big negative I
mean it has I think you know again put
some downward pressure on wages of less
educated workers so both directly in the
sense that you did have some shipment of
jobs and we have a trade deficit on the
order sixty billion a year with Mexico
now would truffle even we had a very
small surplus pre NAFTA you know again
there are other factors there but I
think you have to certainly contributed
that and the other issue is that NAFTA
was often a bargaining tool there's a
professor at the industrial relations
school at Cornell Kate Broughton Brenner
that documented a number of cases where
companies threatened to move to Mexico
if their workers unionized you know so
so I think it was a bargaining tool
again I don't want to say there's huge
effects but I think the effect is
clearly negative under wages of less
educated workers now in looking at US
and Europe you know I look at the
proposal for the TTP and you know this
is primarily about regulation because
already their trade there's very little
by way of formal trade barriers between
the US and Europe I mean we have massive
amount trade the vast majority of which
goes you know passes with zero or very
low tariffs so it's not really about
trade there's it's about putting in
regulations which you know I worry about
a lot of those regulations I mean a lot
of those are you know might limit the
ability of you know if an area state
wants to ban fracking would you be able
to do that in Europe you know GMOs are
more controversial than here the
controversial here but you know the more
restrictions on them there it might
jeopardize that and of course you set up
this investor state dispute settlement
tribunal very hard to justify people are
familiar with is basically a special
tribunal an extrajudicial tribunal that
only investors could bring cases before
and you know when I first was talking to
European reporters about this they
thought I was like some nut ball making
stuff up and go like why do you need
this and well it's a good question but
you know they put that in there it was
in of course it's
the trans-pacific partnership as well
but I don't really understand the logic
of that so you know having freer trade
you know making zeros instead of a half
percent for the tariffs that would be a
good thing but that's not what the TPP
is about does the last point you know I
mean if anyone asked me to the UK you
know I would recommend that they would
go against brexit and obviously the
utilised xenophobia to push that and a
lot about right lines so they said oh
you know we'll get more money for the
National Health Service you know those
those clearly were factors that was both
those were bogus arguments on the other
hand the other side I think exaggerated
case you know UK was supposed to be
thrown into you know a recession and
yeah whatever with you know leaving with
brexit that clearly is not I mean I know
they haven't left yet but you know the
idea was as soon as they had to vote
that you would have this collapse and
that law has not happened I think there
will be negative repercussions for the
UK I mean they they have a very
integrated economy and to suddenly have
a situation I mean we don't know what
sort of barriers we'll have any on the
one hand you have a impulse in Europe to
be very punitive on the other you know
it's punitive to them to them if you put
a big tariffs as Canada to them also the
others saying okay let's negotiate
something that's you know least painful
for both of us
my guess since Germany seems to be
calling the shots as they'll go on the
punitive side and that will be bad news
for them again it's not going to be a
disaster you aren't going to see you
know Second Great Depression UK but I
think it certainly will be a drag on
growth I will make one qualification
here as I say hesitantly because I
haven't studied closely but you know the
big concern in the UK is what will this
do to our finance industry and almost
certainly it will hurt it because as it
stands now you basically you know you
give the finance passport that you know
you take part of so you should really
you can do business really in UK and all
veu that will go away and will certainly
will go away with brexit that would be a
big hit to their financial industry and
I'm not sure that's a bad thing so so
that's why you know again I don't know
if I want to push that too far because
they haven't stayed closely enough but
but but I do mention that
hi my name is Adams I wanted to ask you
a question about the increasing the NIH
budget I'm certainly a big fan of
bumping up the NIH budget I think they
do great work especially for basic
research that kind of leads into applied
research in the pharmaceutical sector my
question is if we have NIH effectively
assume the role of the pharmacy
and bring you bring down to zero these
terrorists as you call them how are we
going to get other countries in the
world to contribute to our research
because we currently sell probably 75%
of our drugs outside of our borders
wouldn't this essentially be forfeiting
all of that income and if we do that in
other countries kind of copy us you know
maybe we're large enough to absorb that
hit and only get 25 percent of the
revenue or the but what happens to a
country like Switzerland which has a
thriving pharmaceutical sector and
benefits the whole world you know
they're probably 1% of the market how
are they going to survive it's really
good question oh you need some sort of
international arrangement and I've races
with people they go oh you want this big
international well what do you think you
guys are doing with the TPP and the
trips I mean so those are all very
complicated - so the idea that somehow
we have this just natural system and I
want to replace it with some complex
system well no we have a very very
complex system now and I want replace it
with a different system what I would
envision is that you would have
something where countries have to
contribute to research based on you know
their their GDP and per capita GDP so
you know the u.s. is expected to
contribute a higher share of its GDP
than say a country like Congo where
maybe they just make a token
contribution you know they're not
expected to making any real payment and
you say to whom well what I would
envision again you'd have to work this
out more depth obviously you need a
fully work out story but you'd have some
rating system where you go okay you know
here here here are intermediaries that
have had a very good record in the sense
that they've produced you know good
developments good research good drugs
you contribute a dollar then it counts
as a dollar here's a second tier you
contribute a dollar to them accounts
seventy-five cents here's a third-tier
they don't have a good record at all you
contribute a dollar and counts as 40
cents and below that doesn't count at
all I mean that would be the sort of
thing at least in my view that you would
want so you need some sort of
international agreement and again if we
could get international agreements on
patents and those are very complex
because they go way beyond patents they
go to you know marketing exclusivity
data exclusivity all these other issues
so the idea that somehow what we have
now is very simple and natural and I'm
talking about something very complex
clearly or complex issues with it but
what we have today is very complex as
well
think about distribution of income that
goes ain't it pushed up so the method
you're suggesting I understand is that
it breaks it down and prevents the
income being pushed up so much it's
explosive Doug and maybe before it gets
all the way to the target redistributed
in other way what if we just let it all
the way go up and then tax it from the
top and then have the government and it
as it is right which one of you mean do
you think there are pros and cons
comparing well so the question is do we
want you know we're concerned by the
inequality so we try and address it as a
before market story and try to prevent
people from getting so rich to begin
with alternatively do we try to say okay
we'll like you guys get really rich and
then we're going to tax it away make
sure that everyone has you know fair
income however we decide that I'm
strongly in favor of going to form
around for two reasons one is you know
the you know we brought in our
right-wingers here they would
immediately jumping up and down you know
okay you know you give us these really
high tax rates you're going to take away
incentive they exaggerate that but there
is something to it and what I emphasize
actually more in the incentive is that
you're giving them a lot of money you're
putting a lot of money on the table for
them to avoid your taxes and the tax
avoidance industry in the u.s. is very
big and very profitable you know the
private equity business to a very large
extent is a tax avoidance industry and
some people get extremely rich on in
private equity think of Mitt Romney and
he's actually one of the poorer ones you
know we talk about the private equity
partners people make hundreds of
millions and often billions basically
finding clever ways to avoid taxes so
that's you know one set of concerns the
other one is just a political one it is
very very hard you know both because you
know people have this idea that you
earned your money you want to take it
away and the other is okay if you've
given these people billions they're
going to spend a lot on politicians and
TV ads and all these other things and
think tanks saying how horrible would be
to tax it away so that my view it makes
much more sense let's not have a system
that leads so much inequality and
you can at least as I try to argue in
the book if you could do that and not
pay a price you know I'm saying that you
know we could finance the pharmaceutical
research in a way that's much more
efficient and doesn't lead to people
becoming immensely rich I mean some
people might get very rich you know my
view you know someone develops a great
new cure for type of cancer give that
person 10 million 20 million and you
know that's fine I mean what I problems
with her you know like our pharma bro
who got you know how much money for you
know finding clever way to jack up
prices actually generic drugs but in any
case you know that's what you don't want
you know so and unfortunately is a lot
of cases like that you know Turk I left
out finance or merrily I beat up on
finance but you know you have partners
and hedge funds where you know they can
make hundreds of millions a year and
what their contribution is they've
developed a sophisticated algorithm that
lets them get in on trades you know
maybe a hundredth of a second ahead of
the competition so they can make an
enormous amount of money because they
see there's this big move on G stack so
they buy in ahead of everyone else and
then they sell it back and maybe there's
just made you know a tenth of a
percentage point or something but it's
not a huge amount of borrowed money and
you do that many times a day you get
very rich that's not something that
contributes to society
hi Dean I wanted to ask a more general
question of you because I've been having
a debate with a friend who tends towards
the libertarian side and I think that he
he has a certain point about government
inefficiency I don't want to put words
in your mouth but I assume that you're
more of an advocate for the welfare
state style government like what we have
seen in Europe in the past although
that's being degraded maybe I'm wrong
about that
but I just I can understand that
argument because I have another friend
who qualified for Medicaid after
Obamacare was put in but the efficiency
the inefficiency that she had to deal
with was absolutely staggering she she
had to she was counting she was taking
notes she had to contact the the
pertinent agency in DC 38 times by
telephone or by email before they
finally granted her Medicaid and then
two years later they took it away
because they said that she didn't
provide the proper documentation even
though she had tried to so that for me
was kind of an eye-opening experience
about the problems that come up with
when you're when you're increasing the
size of government and introducing more
government programs this is very good
question I'm stupid like those concerns
and actually a lot of what I'm saying in
the book isn't necessarily increasing
the size of government increasing it
changes the way government acts so you
know one of my main my pet peeves is
there's the tendency to think of
government in terms of okay government
spending well what I'm pointing out when
government gives you a pet monopoly
that's also very big intervention the
economy and I love these kind of owe the
debt people oh my god you know what are
we doing our children go we gave these
companies patent
they're going to charge us 430 billion
for drugs that would cost us 40 billion
in free market you're not counting that
well that's the same as if we allow them
to pose a tax or if the government
imposed a tax it's the same thing so
anyhow you know what what I'm concerned
about is that we think we have to look
at the way government affects the
economy more broadly rather than just
taxing and spending but you know that is
a real concern and we're it advocated
you know government expansion I it's
generally a fairly narrow way so you
know Social Security again I have done a
lot of work on a lot of research it is
more efficient than the private
alternatives and I you know debated many
of these people I remember debating some
guy from Cato and he goes to one
old-fashioned one size fits all and I go
yeah you know it's old-fashioned kind of
like the wheel you know it does what
it's supposed to do and we want it to be
one size fits all because it's your
basic income so you know I decide oh I
want to have more than just my Social
Security I'll put money in a 401k or
other you know private things that's
fine you know and we got to do some
things on that as well I'll say but in
any case you know the idea of Social
Security that's supposed to be your core
retirement income we want everyone to
have it and having something very simple
is a good thing to do same with Medicare
you know I think in general Medicare's
you know I'm sorry about your friends
bit story I should give you some my
wife's with the private insurer I had
been fortunate generally had good health
but my wife's had lots of bad problems
with private insurers so it's the
government doesn't have a monopoly on
inefficiency I'll just say that but but
I am mindful and that's why you know
again when I was talking about you know
having the research having the
government fund the research I was
saying the government would pay industry
you know you'd contract out and the
analogy I often make here you could
settle that you like the analogy or not
the the military sector we contract that
out and there is wasted military sector
but on the other hand we do develop very
good weapon systems I mean I like what
they use them for it but they are a very
good weapon systems and the big
advantage you would have with
pharmaceutical research as compared to
the military is there's no justification
for secrecy I mean with the military
they actually do have an argument they
might carry too far but they do have an
argument for not putting their latest
weapons system on the web so that you
know Isis whoever can get it know
they're there actually is an argument
whereas with pharmaceutical research
what's your argument we
want people to take your research and
use it so you know so I actually you
know again I take seriously that you
know governments can be inefficient and
we don't want government to do things
it's not good at and that's a lot of
things but you know again I'm not I
don't envision huge of expansion of
government in this story so I guess two
more questions
two more yes there are two more
absolutely thank you very much for your
interesting there are two factors that
that I would have brought up as being
central to the growth of inequality that
that you didn't really talk about and
the the first is the assault on trade
unions that starts in the late 1970s and
and really developed through the 1980s
into the present time and it seems to me
that's absolutely fundamental for
understanding the growth of inequality
and the second was mentioned we talked
about it you talked about it a few
minutes ago but is taxation and starting
with proposition 13 in the 1970s the
tremendous regressive taxation system
that developed in comparison say to the
post-war years
massive tax cuts for the wealthy and it
seems to me those two factors really are
the are the arguably the most important
ones well taking the second one first
two reasons why I don't spend a lot of
time talking about taxes one or I guess
three I should say one is I'm
deliberately trying to talk about before
tax income which you know which I'll say
is where you've seen most of the
increase in inequality and there's
actually pretty good research on this
the impact we definitely see lower tax
rates obviously you know currently too
low over 40% we had 90 percent top
marginal tax rate back in you know the
50s death has been largely offset by
fewer loopholes so if you look at the
share of income of the top 1% that's
being paid in taxes it's
down but not buy anywhere near as much
as would be suggested by just looking at
that 90 percent verse forty percent tax
rate so that's not as important as it
may seem the third point I just say is
that there are a lot of people that do
that work and they do some very good
work citizens for tax justice and budget
policy priority they do very good work
on that so you know I think that you
know people I think generally know that
story
the other story labor unions this is
very important you talk about the book
and that is something that definitely is
affected by an institution so there's a
story that you know has a lot of
currency well people just aren't your
stress interest in labor unions anymore
so if we go back to the late 70s you
know unionization rates somewhere around
20 percent give or take today it's I'm
scared to say well we have about 9% you
know so we've seen plummeting in the
share of the workforce that's
represented by unions even more insulin
private sector private sector were down
around 7 and that was also around 20%
back in the late 70s but we did a paper
a few years ago that looked at Canada
and reason why we looked at can those
can is a very similar country you know
it's big English or most I'm speaking
English and you know just north of the
border very similar economy there's no
remotely comparable decline in their
unionization rate you know if you go
back to like 70s something like 35% by
these aren't exact numbers today might
be 32% you know so it's down but down
trivially nothing like the collapse
we've seen in the US so what's the big
difference well Canada you know there
are things like you know automatic you
know card check you could sign up for
Union by you know card sign off majority
sign off they also first contract
arbitration so they have rules like that
which we don't have here also you can't
fire striking workers as you can here so
we had a lot of changes in rules and
norms in the last four decades that have
made it very difficult for unions to
organize or to stay in business so that
is a big part of the picture you know
again in perhaps as I mentioned this I
played you talk about in the book and
you're absolutely right to bring it up
and one more question if there's one
you have a comment on the recent
information about six richest guys in
the world equally now the bottom half of
the planet yeah people don't see this
there was a study by Oxfam that I think
those eight people the richest eight
people you know the obvious suspects
Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos and Mark
Zuckerberg and Warren Buffett does swim
whenever Sanders from Mexico so so
there's eight people most of them from
the US for better or worse and they have
more wealth by their calculations on the
bottom fifty fifty percent of the world
population I mean it speaks volumes of
the inequalities I mean you have you
have an awful lot of people are
incredibly poor in some ways that is
more the story I mean obviously people
are incredibly rich I mean Gates have
something like seventy billion I mean
divide that by a hundred he's still
incredibly rich I mean you know it's
amazing how much money this guy has but
you know in many ways I think the more
dramatic story is how poor so many
people are so you know I if I you know I
have to check the exact numbers but I
suspect that I have more wealth than the
bottom 25% of the world population and
it's not because I'm not kidding
billionaire or something it's because
the bottom 25% is zero you know they're
negative you know so so it we do some
people are incredibly rich but you know
probably the bigger part of that story
is we have you know an incredible number
of people you know say a quarter of the
world's population somewhere on the
order of two billion people but
basically a zero you know just a pretty
dismal story
and yeah well thanks for listening and
so I don't have to be I don't to be
embarrassed like Donald Trump will be on
Friday when no one shows up for his
inauguration thank you well he was um he
could be right over the inside of the
cottage of the book they are on sale for
$9.99 almost a cost and if you already
have a copy of the book footboards you
want to learn more about things work on
the book contorted seaport feel free to
check out dean baker dotnet there's even
get a like try a copy of the book for
free Buchanan's just because he does
walk the walk and talk the talk about
that right here for you for free so yeah
go over on get a book signed and don't
forget to take care of your waiters and
waitresses will be good for tonight and
one more time with evening
[Applause]